Lucia: 哎底下是啥又看不清
Lucia: Hey, what's that below? I can't see clearly.
其他人：这是一个非常高的赞许
其他人：非常可逃
Others: Very escapable.
其他人：他刚在刚在小红书上钓鱼
Others: He was just fishing on Little Red Book.
其他人：钓到了我自己的同学
Others: Caught my own classmate.
其他人：抽象死
Shure: 那个这个
Shure: That, this...
其他人：现在两个就可以了哦
Others: Now two are enough.
其他人：中间的步骤我是不会的
Others: I don't know the steps in between.
其他人：哈哈哈真好
Others: Hahaha, that's great.
Shure:  没事两个人喝
Shure: It's fine, two people can drink.
Katrina: 这个二楼藏了多少个啊
Katrina: How many are hidden on the second floor?
Lucia: 二楼我们昨天真的藏了吗
Lucia: Did we really hide anything on the second floor yesterday?
Katrina: 这二楼我们昨天真的藏了吗
Katrina: Did we really hide anything on the second floor yesterday?
其他人：你藏了吗
Others: Did you hide anything?
Katrina: 我没藏
Katrina: I didn't hide anything.
其他人：那二楼没有了
Others: Then there's nothing on the second floor.
其他人：金康
Others: Jin Kang.
Jake:没有也可以找啊
Jake: If there's nothing, we can still find something.
Lucia: 那要不我们现场藏吧
Lucia: How about we hide it on the spot?
Lucia: 请嘉宾先去一楼
Lucia: Let's have the guests go to the first floor first.
其他人：嘉宾可以先去一楼找一下
Others: Guests can go to the first floor to find it first.
Katrina: 那咱咱们那个贴纸呢
Katrina: So, where are our stickers?
Lucia: 一楼刚才有个妹子好像找的差不多了
Lucia: A girl on the first floor almost found them.
Lucia: 我感觉他找到了咱
Lucia: I think she found our
Lucia: 们的那个一包没拆开的
Lucia: unopened pack.
其他人：那个一包没拆开
Others: The unopened pack.
Lucia: 然后他终结了游戏
Lucia: And then she ended the game.
Lucia: 哈哈啊
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 贴纸在哪
Katrina: Where are the stickers?
Lucia: 一整包了吗
Lucia: The whole pack?
其他人：我去我去
Others: I'll go, I'll go.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 那你先下去然后他们藏一下
Katrina: You go down first and hide them.
Shure: 我们喝咖啡吧哈哈哈
Shure: Let's have some coffee, haha.
Katrina: 然后你来找吧
Katrina: Then you come to find them.
Katrina: 就这个这个女生
Katrina: Just this girl.
Katrina: 我们两男
Katrina: The two of us guys.
Katrina: 然后四个女生嘛
Katrina: And four girls.
Katrina: 还有两个女生在楼下
Katrina: Two more girls downstairs.
Katrina: 一个是那个做蛋糕的
Katrina: One who makes cakes.
Katrina: 还有一个就是那个
Katrina: And the other one,
Katrina: 反正戴眼镜的就是这样
Katrina: the one with glasses.
Katrina: 然后其他就是邀请过来的朋友
Katrina: The rest are invited friends.
Shure: 他放点冰淇淋
Shure: He put some ice cream.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 我开了空调
Katrina: I turned on the AC.
Katrina: 靠二楼好热
Katrina: It's so hot on the second floor.
Katrina: 遥控器呢
Katrina: Where's the remote?
Katrina: 贴纸在我这吗不是
Katrina: Are the stickers with me? No.
Lucia: 哎不是我的
Lucia: Hey, not mine.
Lucia: 差点给收走了
Lucia: Almost got taken away.
Jake:什么
Jake: What?
Jake:GPT
Jake: GPT.
Jake:没了
Jake: It's gone.
Lucia: 我先去楼下收缴一个充电宝上来啊
Lucia: I'll go downstairs and get a power bank.
Lucia: 收缴一个
Lucia: Get a power bank.
Katrina: 要不先下一楼我们藏一下
Katrina: How about we go to the first floor and hide?
Katrina: 藏吧
Katrina: Let's hide.
Alice: 你可以用我的充这个
Alice: You can use my charger.
Alice: 这个充电宝上有那个那个啥连的线
Alice: This power bank has that, um, connected wire.
Alice: 这呢
Alice: Here.
Alice: 对
Alice: Yeah.
Alice: 这个眼镜是要充着电用哎
Alice: These glasses need to be charged.
Alice: 要不你搁那充吧
Alice: Why don't you charge them there?
Alice: 你看那底下那不
Alice: Look under there.
Alice: 哎呀这缺的就是充电宝
Alice: Oh, we just need the power bank.
Alice: 你瞅见了吗
Alice: Do you see it?
Alice: 这不充电宝是啥呀
Alice: Isn't this a power bank?
Alice: 充上呗
Alice: Just charge it.
其他人：研究研究
Others: Let's figure it out.
Alice: 研究吧
Alice: Let's figure it out.
Alice: 我怎么就一个了呢
Alice: Why do I only have one?
Alice: 但是好像是头不太对
Alice: But the head doesn't seem right.
其他人：这我给他
Others: I'll give this to him.
Alice: 那你用我这个吧
Alice: Then use mine.
其他人： 我觉得我觉得我找这地方真的太
Others: I think finding this place is really too...
Katrina: 干嘛我又没有USB接口
Katrina: What? I don't have a USB port.
Katrina: 真没有
Katrina: Really, I don't.
Lucia: oh heal the word
Lucia: Oh, heal the world.
Shure: 符合一下你的习惯
Shure: To match your habits.
Lucia: （歌词）there are people dying
Lucia: (lyrics) There are people dying.
Lucia: （歌词）if you care enough for the living
Lucia: (lyrics) If you care enough for the living.
Lucia: （歌词）for you and for me
Lucia: (lyrics) For you and for me.
Lucia: （歌词）so know why there's a love that cannot lie
Lucia: (lyrics) So know why there's a love that cannot lie.
Lucia: 可以我喜欢这个主题曲
Lucia: Alright, I like this theme song.
其他人：我藏完了
Others: I'm done hiding.
其他人：如果有一个是从我这找到的我就输
Others: If anyone finds it from me, I lose.
Lucia: （歌词）still is still living
Lucia: (lyrics) Still is still living.
Lucia: （歌词） always love is enough as growing
Lucia: (lyrics) Always love is enough as growing.
其他人：我们桌面有一种0
Others: Our desktop has a zero.
Shure: 嗯他这分辨率就就就会这个样子
Shure: Yeah, its resolution just ends up like this.
Lucia: （歌词）make it a better place for you and for me
Lucia: (lyrics) Make it a better place for you and for me.
Lucia: （歌词）and the entire human race and all people dying
Lucia: (lyrics) And the entire human race and all people dying.
Lucia: （歌词）if you care enough for the living
Lucia: (lyrics) If you care enough for the living.
Lucia: （歌词）a joyful face and the lonely woman leaving with shiny grand
Lucia: (lyrics) A joyful face and the lonely woman leaving with shiny grand.
Lucia: （歌词）Grace and white wolf keeps changing the light
Lucia: (lyrics) Grace and white wolf keeps changing the light.
Lucia: （歌词）till his earth comes out so忘词了
Lucia: （歌词）fantasy was heavenly becomes gone
Lucia: (lyrics) Fantasy was heavenly becomes gone.
Shure: 这照片是你吗哈哈哈
Shure: Is this photo of you? Hahaha.
其他人：讨厌
Others: Annoying.
Lucia: （歌词）let our spirits never join
Lucia: (singing) Let our spirits never join.
Shure: 是咱闺女是吧哈哈哈
Shure: That's our daughter, right? Hahaha.
其他人：那是你妹妹好
Others: That's your sister, okay?
其他人：那是你姐姐好
Others: That's your big sister, okay?
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
其他人：我是他妈
Others: I'm his mom.
其他人： 来接孩子放学呢
Others: Here to pick him up from school.
其他人：妈有什么东西
Others: Mom, what's for lunch?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: you're the one make it a better place
Lucia: You're the one who makes it a better place.
Lucia: （歌词）for you and for me and the entire human race
Lucia: (singing) For you and for me and the entire human race.
Lucia: （歌词）there are people knowing if you care enough for the living
Lucia: (singing) There are people knowing if you care enough for the living.
Lucia: （歌词）make a better place you have for me
Lucia: (singing) Make a better place, you have for me.
Katrina: 刚才那个男的不是
Katrina: Wasn't that guy just now...
Katrina: 哈哈哈刚刚那个男的
Katrina: Hahaha, that guy just now...
Shure: 揣在兜里怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with keeping it in my pocket?
Shure: 这一脸无奈
Shure: Look at that helpless face.
Katrina: 别这么痴呆吧
Katrina: Don't look so dazed.
Katrina: 你要睡了
Katrina: Are you going to sleep?
Shure: 来杯咖啡吧
Shure: How about a cup of coffee?
Shure: 谢老板
Shure: Thanks, boss.
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Oh my God.
Katrina: 我每天三点钟睡都有人在这走动
Katrina: I go to bed at 3 AM every day and there's always someone walking around.
Shure: 谢老板来杯咖啡吗
Shure: Thanks, boss. Want a cup of coffee?
Katrina: 然后每天11点钟起床
Katrina: Then I wake up at 11 AM every day.
Katrina: 耶找到一个
Katrina: Yay, found one!
Shure: 好谢老板感冒了
Shure: Alright, boss has a cold.
Katrina: 交给谁呢
Katrina: Who should I give it to?
Katrina: 交给货币发起人吧
Katrina: Give it to the currency initiator.
Katrina: 你保管货币吗
Katrina: Do you manage the currency?
Katrina: 休叔
Katrina: Shure.
Katrina: 你保管吧
Katrina: You manage it.
Shure: 我保管了
Shure: I'll take care of it.
Katrina: 你不是货币发起人吗
Katrina: Aren't you the currency initiator?
Shure: 这这还有假币是吗
Shure: Wait, is there counterfeit money?
Katrina: 这这这个也算吧
Katrina: This one could count, right?
Shure: 假币
Shure: Counterfeit money.
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
其他人：我先我先刻意
Others: I'll go first, I'll go first on purpose.
Shure: 你不能偷
Shure: You can't steal.
Shure: 我们这通货是固定的好吗
Shure: Our currency is fixed, okay?
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Katrina: 这是吗这好像不是吧
Katrina: Is this it? This doesn't seem right.
Shure: 是
Shure: It is.
Shure: 这是这是
Shure: This is it.
Katrina: 可以是
Katrina: It could be.
Shure: 完了开始已经有假币流入市场了
Shure: Oh no, fake currency has started to circulate in the market.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
其他人：你刚刚给我几个
Others: How many did you give me just now?
Katrina: 给了你4个好像
Katrina: I think I gave you 4.
Shure: 这个镜子照人显高你知道吗
Shure: This mirror makes you look taller, did you know?
Shure: 不要一脸嫌弃的眼神看着我
Shure: Don't look at me with that disdainful expression.
其他人：我在一楼藏的也都没找到
Others: I hid it on the first floor but couldn't find it.
其他人：我发现我非常适合藏东西
Others: I realized I'm really good at hiding things.
Lucia: 啊不行
Lucia: Ah, no.
Lucia: 我还得把这继续揣着
Lucia: I need to keep this with me.
Lucia: 揣着揣着吧
Lucia: I'll just keep it.
其他人：: 给你们仨都带走咋地
Alice: 是不是我的呀
Alice: Is this mine?
Alice: 啊啊啊
Alice: Ahhh!
Alice: 没事不是我的
Alice: Never mind, it's not mine.
Lucia: 啊我没有废弃的瓶盖吗
Lucia: Ah, don't I have any discarded bottle caps?
Alice: 那个看看见好像没有人用哎
Alice: That one seems unused.
Alice: 这个这个
Alice: This one, this one.
Lucia: 嗯行
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 要不我把这个拿去试试
Lucia: How about I try this one?
Alice: 啊啊那也是
Alice: Ah, yeah, that's right.
Alice: 要不你玩那个拼图吧
Alice: Or you could do that puzzle.
Alice: 我看你在这挺没事干的
Alice: You seem pretty idle here.
其他人: 我刚刚手机充着电呢，我一会又要开始使
Alice: OK
Alice: OK.
Tasha: 等一下我已经再准备了
Tasha: Wait a second, I'm getting ready.
Tasha: 这是要做什么
Tasha: What are we going to do?
Alice:麻薯
Alice: Mochi.
Alice: 你这特别像一个什么神仙下凡
Alice: You really look like some kind of fairy descending to earth.
Alice: 你这装扮
Alice: Your outfit.
Alice: 你这大赤耳朵
Alice: And those big red ears.
Alice: 有福之相
Alice: You look blessed.
其他人：你这给我都粘进去了
Others: You stuck it all in here for me.
Alice: 那不是你自己粘的吗
Alice: Didn't you stick it yourself?
其他人：你粘的
Other: You stuck it.
Alice: 你放什么屁呢
Alice: What nonsense are you talking about?
其他人：看你干的好事
Other: Look what you've done.
Alice: 那不你自己粘的吗
Alice: Didn't you stick it yourself?
其他人：我粘的是你耳朵上的
Other: I stuck it on your ear.
Alice: 你耳朵是你自己粘的呀你忘了
Alice: You stuck it on your own ear, did you forget?
其他人：你不粘的吗
Other: Didn't you stick it?
Alice: 我没给你粘
Alice: I didn't stick it for you.
Alice: 你自己粘的
Alice: You stuck it yourself.
Alice: 你怎么乱污蔑人呢你这人
Alice: Why are you falsely accusing people?
其他人：社会乱家哈哈哈
Other: Society's a mess, hahaha.
Alice: 我知道
Alice: I know.
Tasha: 挤吧挤挤
Tasha: Squeeze, squeeze.
Tasha: 一个小团子一个小团子
Tasha: One little ball at a time.
Alice: 挤一个爱心型的
Alice: Squeeze a heart-shaped one.
Alice: 哈哈哈送给刘婷哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha, give it to Liu Ting, hahaha.
Tasha: 那挤不出来
Tasha: It can't be squeezed out.
Alice: 好油啊你没人管管她吗
Alice: So greasy, can't someone control her?
Katrina: 微微那个空调遥控器有在你房间吗
Katrina: Tasha, do you have the air conditioner remote in your room?
Tasha: 不在
Tasha: No, I don't.
Katrina: 也不在我房间哎
Katrina: It's not in my room either.
Katrina: 在你房间吗
Katrina: Is it in your room?
Katrina: 露西嗯
Katrina: Lucia?
Lucia: 呃应该没有
Lucia: Uh, I don't think so.
Lucia: 我从来没有见到
Lucia: I've never seen it.
Katrina: 哇你这样子玩的吗
Katrina: Wow, is this how you play?
Lucia: 哈哈因为我没有打火机
Lucia: Haha, because I don't have a lighter.
Katrina: 你问那个
Katrina: Ask that...
Katrina: 谢谢谢冰烛借就行
Katrina: Borrow it from Xie Bingzhu, it's fine.
Lucia: 他那个打火机好像棉芯有点用完了
Lucia: His lighter's wick seems to be worn out.
Lucia: 然后就不太好着
Lucia: So it's hard to light.
Lucia: 我昨天晚上试了一下
Lucia: I tried it last night.
Tasha: 不然我拿不下来
Tasha: Otherwise, I can't take it down.
Katrina: 完了没空调遥控器
Katrina: Now there's no air conditioner remote.
Tasha: 拿不下来了已经
Tasha: I can't take it down anymore.
Lucia: 那个空调遥控器我好像就没怎么见过
Lucia: I don't think I've ever really seen the air conditioner remote.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Ugh.
Katrina: 这有一个空调遥控器应该都能通用吧
Katrina: This air conditioner remote should be universal, right?
Katrina: 这这个
Katrina: This one...
Tasha: 太小了再挤大一点
Tasha: It's too small, squeeze a bigger one.
Alice:太小了
Alice: It's too small.
Lucia: 感觉他会掉哎
Lucia: Feels like it might fall.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: It's fine.
Alice: 好热呀你热不热薇薇
Alice: It's so hot, aren't you hot, Tasha?
Tasha: 还好就这么大就行
Tasha: It's okay, this size is fine.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 拯救2楼
Katrina: Saving the second floor.
Katrina: 我以为你背吉他来了
Katrina: I thought you came with a guitar.
Lucia: （歌词）make it a better place
Lucia: (Lyrics) make it a better place.
Lucia: （歌词）for you and for me and day
Lucia: (Lyrics) for you and for me and day.
其他人：卖菠萝蛋糕的那个商家说了
Others: The seller of the pineapple cake said.
其他人：平台上面没有显示
Others: It's not displayed on the platform.
Alice: 那怎么办你为什么不给我勾一个
Alice: Then what to do, why don't you mark it for me?
其他人：不出意外的话
Others: If nothing goes wrong.
Alice: 你要买现成的
Alice: You need to buy a ready-made one.
其他人：那你就8倍就能收到啊
Others: Then you can receive it eight times.
其他人：我估计我做出来的时候
Others: I guess by the time I make it.
其他人：我可能烧给你了
Others: I might burn it for you.
其他人：你别整了
Others: Stop messing around.
Alice: 行在你
Alice: Fine, it's up to you.
Alice: 我在你心里就只这一点点位置
Alice: In your heart, I only have this little space.
Alice: 你不会为我学吗
Alice: You wouldn't learn for me?
Lucia: 嗯啊我试图粘一个水母出来
Lucia: Yeah, I tried to make a jellyfish.
Lucia: 本来是要做一个水母灯的
Lucia: Originally wanted to make a jellyfish lamp.
Lucia: 但是没有买灯珠
Lucia: But didn't buy the lamp beads.
Lucia: 忘记了
Lucia: Forgot about it.
Lucia: i hope
Lucia: I hope.
其他人：啊好可爱
Others: Ah, so cute.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This.
Lucia: 材料有点有点缺乏
Lucia: The materials are a bit lacking.
Lucia: 希望他能粘出一个相对还凑合的造型
Lucia: Hope it can be glued into a somewhat decent shape.
Alice: 你用它测测你心里的温度吧
Alice: Use it to measure the temperature in your heart.
Alice: 我觉得
Alice: I think.
Lucia: 我感觉胶有点少
Lucia: I feel like there's not enough glue.
Alice: 零下200度
Alice: Minus 200 degrees.
Lucia: 这个条我昨天晚上已经烧过了
Lucia: This strip, I already burned it last night.
其他人：啊
Others: Ah.
Lucia: 对只要把它粘一下
Lucia: Yeah, just need to glue it.
Lucia: 然后里面再加一点珠子就可以了
Lucia: Then add some beads inside and it'll be fine.
Lucia: 但是
Lucia: But...
其他人：   就这两个角啊
Others: Just these two corners, huh?
Lucia: 有好几个角
Lucia: There are several corners.
Lucia: 咦粘到我手上了
Lucia: Oh, it stuck to my hand.
其他人：啊小心小心
Others: Ah, be careful, be careful.
Lucia: 没事他现在已经不烫了
Lucia: It's okay, it's not hot anymore.
Lucia: 就是会有点拉丝
Lucia: It's just a bit stringy.
Lucia: 我应该刚来那一天就买一个溶胶枪
Lucia: I should have bought a glue gun the day I arrived.
Lucia: 然后我们就很多地方可以用到
Lucia: Then we could have used it in many places.
Tasha: 我看看
Tasha: Let me see.
其他人：啊找到了
Others: Ah, found it.
Alice: 6啊你这眼睛是咋长的呀
Alice: Wow, how did you spot that?
其他人：我的眼睛就是尺
Others: My eyes are like rulers.
其他人：你们都吃了吗
Others: Have you all eaten?
Alice: 让你吃了 不知道呀
Alice: Didn't you eat? No idea.
其他人：你你你有我喊人吗
Others: Did you call anyone?
Alice: 大馋丫头
Alice: Greedy girl.
其他人：我没有啊
Others: I didn't.
其他人：露西亚你有喊人
Others: Lucia, did you call anyone?
Lucia: 呃我有一个朋友可能会来哦对然后
Lucia: Uh, I have a friend who might come, oh right, and...
Alice:给你个原味儿的
Alice: Here's an original flavor one for you.
Alice: 给
Alice: Here.
Jake: 我们现在
Jake: We now...
其他人：这差不多应该算齐了
Others: This should be about right.
Jake: 我们现在算齐了
Jake: We now have everything.
其他人： 有可能会到
Others: It might arrive.
Lucia: 对他有可能来哦就呵呵呵对
Lucia: Yeah, he might come, haha, yeah.
Jake: 哦这么 呵呵呵
Jake: Oh, really? Haha.
Jake:  好嘞好的没关系
Jake: Alright, no problem.
Jake: 那我们就
Jake: Then we will...
Lucia: 因为理论上说就是就是
Lucia: Because theoretically, he...
Lucia: 那个男生
Lucia: That guy...
Lucia: 他今天应该会就是有时间应该会过来
Lucia: He should have time to come today.
Lucia: 不过他现在没跟我说他到哪了
Lucia: But he hasn't told me where he is now.
Jake: 好没关系
Jake: It's fine.
Lucia: 那个妹子的话
Lucia: As for the girl...
Lucia: 他因为太远了就不太方便
Lucia: It's too far for her, not very convenient.
Lucia: 如果他来的话就要来两个小时左右
Lucia: If she comes, it will take about two hours.
Lucia: 然后回去还得回两个小时
Lucia: And then another two hours to get back.
Lucia: 就不是很方便
Lucia: So it's not very convenient.
其他人：因为把这些凳子要搬上去
Others: Because these chairs need to be moved upstairs.
Jake: 哎你你来搬
Jake: Hey, you, come and move this.
其他人：哦她们不是在坐着吗
Others: Oh, aren't they sitting over there?
Jake: 我我们开开个场吧要不 往后摆 然后
Jake: Let's, let's start with an opening, maybe move it back, and then...
其他人：还是让他们坐比如坐垫子上
Others: Or let them sit on cushions, for example.
Jake: 我想一想
Jake: Let me think about it.
Jake: 哎我想一想
Jake: Hey, let me think about it.
Jake: 这边可能
Jake: Maybe over here...
Lucia: 关一下
Lucia: Close it.
Katrina: 还可以在这贴两个
Katrina: We can stick two more here.
Shure: yes
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 这我们得都上去
Jake: We need to get up there.
Jake: 那这个我们能上去搞
Jake: Can we get up there to do it?
Jake: 吗对
Jake: Right?
Alice: 这个快这个快
Alice: This is quick, this is quick.
Alice: 弄好对了
Alice: Done correctly.
其他人：要不搞完再上去
Jake:对 要不这一波
Jake: Right, how about this round...
Jake: 这这这一波
Jake: This, this, this round...
Jake: 这波搞完
Jake: Finish this round...
Jake: 我上去
Jake: I'll go up.
Jake: 好行
Jake: Okay, deal.
Jake: 上去就介绍一下
Jake: I'll go up and give a brief introduction.
Jake: 然后开场
Jake: Then an opening.
Jake: 呃到处每个房间走一走
Jake: Uh, walk around each room.
Jake: 装饰完了吗
Jake: Are the decorations done?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Jake: 那
Jake: Then...
Katrina: 但我已经收拾干净了
Katrina: But I've already cleaned up.
Jake: 好那就可以看是吧
Jake: Alright, then we can look, right?
Tasha: 熟了还没有配料呢
Tasha: It's cooked but lacks seasonings.
Jake: 还可以看
Jake: We can still look.
Jake: 那什么时候能出完全品
Jake: When will the finished product be ready?
Katrina: 完完
Katrina: Done, done.
Tasha: 不行没有配料不好吃
Tasha: No, without seasonings, it won't taste good.
Jake: 完全品
Jake: Finished product.
Jake: 完全的屋子
Jake: The complete room.
Katrina: 啊今天晚上就行啊
Katrina: Ah, it will be ready tonight.
Jake: 完整状态
Jake: Complete state.
Lucia: 呃对但是上去之前
Lucia: Uh, yes, but before going up...
Jake: 今晚完整状态
Jake: Tonight in complete state.
Lucia: 我会需要把那个东西再粘一下
Lucia: I'll need to glue that thing again.
Lucia: 不然他就会掉
Lucia: Otherwise, it's gonna fall off.
其他人：我们可以先寻别的房间
Others: We can check out other rooms first.
Lucia: 哈哈可以
Lucia: Haha, sure.
Lucia: 对对对你
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, you guys
Lucia: 们去别的房间的时候
Lucia: go to other rooms,
Lucia: 我就溜进去整理我的
Lucia: and I'll sneak in and tidy up my stuff.
其他人：哈哈哎哎
Others: Haha, okay.
其他人：你往这个角度看是OK的
Others: If you look from this angle, it’s fine.
Lucia: 对就是他这里还有两条腿
Lucia: Yeah, it still has two legs here.
其他人：你看多好
Others: See, it looks great.
Jake: 是好玩
Jake: It’s fun.
Lucia: 把它粘好
Lucia: Glue it properly.
Jake: 一个奔跑的 水母
Jake: A running jellyfish.
Lucia: 理论上说应该是
Lucia: Theoretically, it should be
Lucia: 就是完全的造型应该这样
Lucia: this way for the complete look.
Lucia: 然后中间会再有串珠坠下来这个
Lucia: And there should be beads hanging down in the middle.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 但这个有点小不太好做
Lucia: But it's a bit small and hard to make.
Jake:没关系个
Jake: No problem.
Alice: 这是熟的 蒸过的
Alice: This is cooked, steamed.
Alice: 怎么我还能毒死你啊毒死你也不会在这哎
Alice: What, you think I could poison you? If I did, you wouldn’t be here, haha.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈真他妈上头你说什么
Alice: Hahahaha, that’s so freaking awesome, what did you say?
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
其他人：好上午搞了9个坐位
Others: Alright, we got 9 seats this morning.
Jake: 行行行
Jake: Okay, okay.
其他人：啊6个加3个垫子加一个多余的桌子
Others: Yeah, 6 plus 3 cushions plus an extra table.
Alice: 哈哈哈这
Alice: Haha, this
其他人：啊这些凳子可以给它搬上去
Others: We can move these stools up.
其他人：这些感觉放不下
Others: These don’t seem to fit.
其他人：（歌声）你做了什么
Others: (singing) What did you do
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Jake: 可以安上去么
Jake: Can it be installed?
Shure: 也可以vvvip
Shure: Yeah, it can be vvvip.
其他人：那我来骑马
Others: Then I'll ride a horse.
Jake: 好那就算了
Jake: Okay, forget it.
Jake: 太重了是吧
Jake: It’s too heavy, right?
Shure: 你就是nice
Shure: You’re just nice.
Jake: 牛批哎呀
Jake: Awesome, oh man.
Shure: EGO Knight好吧
Shure: EGO Knight, alright.
其他人：他是Ego house
Others: He's from Ego house.
Shure: 他是EGO house
Shure: He's from EGO house.
Shure: 你是IGO Knight
Shure: You are from IGO Knight.
其他人：歧视
Others: Discrimination.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Alice: 你要吃哪个味刘婷
Alice: Which flavor do you want, Liu Ting?
其他人：我觉得这虾球
Others: I think this shrimp ball...
其他人： 都吃不起
Others: ...we can't afford it.
Alice: 不我要给你弄一些小的
Alice: No, I want to get you some small ones.
Shure: 你干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Shure: 不是你你是骑士
Shure: No, you're a knight.
Shure: 戴耳钉会怎么样吗
Shure: What's wrong with wearing earrings?
Alice: 我不爱吃可可
Alice: I don't like cocoa.
其他人：我戴的是耳钉吗
Others: Am I wearing earrings?
其他人：别他妈自我代入
Others: Don't project yourself onto me.
Shure: 你戴的是摇滚是吗哈哈
Shure: You're wearing rock style, right? Haha.
Alice: 我要整个形
Alice: I want a whole shape.
Alice: 爱心
Alice: Heart-shaped.
其他人：恶心啊
Others: Disgusting.
Lucia: 这个爪子
Lucia: This claw...
Lucia: 应该是要在粘的时候再塑性的
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
Lucia: 之前塑出来这个造型
Lucia: If it revives earlier...
Lucia: 他就会往外往外撇嗯
Lucia: ...it will spread outwards, yeah.
其他人：嗯
Others: Yeah.
Lucia: 没事凑合用一下吧
Lucia: It's okay, we'll make do.
Lucia: 啊我小伙伴说他到花庄地铁站了
Lucia: Ah, my friend said he's at Huazhuang subway station.
其他人：让她打车过来吧
Others: Let her take a taxi here.
其他人：然后打的那个地点叫时光旅人5号
Others: And the taxi destination should be Time Traveler No. 5.
其他人：然后我们到那个地方去接他
Others: Then we'll pick her up there.
其他人：叫时光旅人5号院
Others: It's called Time Traveler No. 5 Courtyard.
Alice: 这是耻辱
Alice: This is shameful.
Lucia: 时光旅人5号院
Lucia: Time Traveler No. 5 Courtyard.
其他人：对
Others: Yes.
Alice: 萱哈哈哈哈
Alice: Xuan, hahaha.
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Wait a second.
Lucia: 网又不太好了
Lucia: The internet is bad again.
其他人：没事没事
Others: It's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 你非得要当一把大爷是吗
Shure: Do you have to act like a big shot?
Lucia: 收取中好热
Lucia: It's so hot while charging.
Lucia: 哈哈离炉子太近了
Lucia: Haha, too close to the stove.
Lucia: 等一会
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Shure: 我们给他加油
Shure: Let's cheer him on.
Lucia: 转不出来了
Lucia: It won't turn anymore.
Lucia: 我的手机
Lucia: My phone...
其他人：怎么已经吸不出来水了呢
Others: Why can't it suck up any water?
其他人：是是不是水太少了
Others: Is it because there's too little water?
Lucia: 看起来还有半瓶点
Lucia: Looks like there's still half a bottle.
Alice: 你点他不管用哦
Alice: Tapping it doesn't work.
Alice: 那个啥他没插电吗不是
Alice: Is it not plugged in?
Tasha: 没插电
Tasha: It's not plugged in.
Alice: 你看那个那个那个那个
Alice: Look at that, look at that.
其他人：哦他现在在用是吧
Others: Oh, he's using it now, right?
Alice: 呃哪个不用啊
Alice: Uh, which one isn't in use?
Tasha: 微波炉不用了拔掉吧
Tasha: The microwave isn't in use, unplug it.
Alice: 这个好像不用
Alice: This one seems to be off.
Lucia: 对有一点点
Lucia: Yeah, just a little bit.
Lucia: 哈哈没事做饭还是很容易被烫到的
Lucia: Haha, it's easy to get burned while cooking.
Alice: 要不你去其他地方把它挪走
Alice: How about you move it to another place?
其他人：二楼是不是还有水
Others: Is there water on the second floor?
Tasha: 二楼那个是正常的
Tasha: The one on the second floor is working fine.
Alice: 二楼也有
Alice: There's water on the second floor too.
其他人：我发现我要么就是路亚要么就是路西
Others: I realized I'm either Lucia or Luya.
其他人：啊不然是路亚
Others: Otherwise, I'm Luya.
其他人：这是不对的一个
Others: This is incorrect.
Lucia: 哈哈都可以
Lucia: Haha, either is fine.
Lucia: 等一下我擦擦手
Lucia: Wait a second, I'll wipe my hands.
Lucia: 然后我给他回一下
Lucia: Then I'll reply to him.
Katrina: 你说所有吗
Katrina: You mean all of them?
Lucia: 可以用这个纸
Lucia: You can use this paper.
Katrina: 不止不止
Katrina: Not just, not just.
Katrina: 我们都有
Katrina: We all have it.
Katrina: 10个人加6个嘉宾吧
Katrina: 10 people plus 6 guests.
Lucia: 呃是到哪里啊
Lucia: Uh, where to?
Lucia: 跟他说一下
Lucia: Tell him.
其他人：到时光旅人5号院
Others: To Time Traveler's Courtyard No. 5.
Shure: 在外面呢
Shure: Outside.
Shure: 你打红心
Shure: You call a cab.
其他人：对你说打车吧
Others: Yes, tell him to call a cab.
其他人：因为走路的话走两公里还是太远了
Others: Because walking two kilometers is still too far.
Katrina: 打孔器哈哈哈
Katrina: A hole puncher, hahaha.
其他人：嗯
Others: Hmm.
其他人：这是一个套餐吗
Others: Is this a set meal?
Lucia: 时光旅
Lucia: Time travel.
Katrina: 是我的打孔器呢
Katrina: It's my hole puncher.
Shure: 好好不害臊就行
Shure: It's fine, as long as you're not embarrassed.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yep.
Shure: 我在幼儿园表现可好了
Shure: I was great in kindergarten.
Shure: 完了我的我的
Shure: Oh no, my, my...
Shure: 以为找到了
Shure: I thought I found it.
其他人：你说打车到这边我们就很好接他
Others: You said we'd pick him up if we took a taxi here.
Shure: 我昨天藏这了
Shure: I hid it here yesterday.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay.
Shure: 不要不干什么
Shure: Don't not do anything.
Shure: 你怎么老一脸嫌弃看我
Shure: Why do you always look at me with disgust?
Shure: 快把那天粉衣服那事换上哈哈哈
Shure: Quickly change into that pink outfit from the other day, hahaha.
Katrina: 要上楼吗
Katrina: Do we need to go upstairs?
Shure: 快把妹妹还我
Shure: Quickly give my sister back to me.
Alice: 干什么you jump
Alice: What are you doing? You jump?
其他人：把这个定位转给他一下啊
Others: Send him the location.
Alice: I jump了
Alice: I jumped.
Lucia: 行你把定位转给
Lucia: Okay, send him the location.
Shure: 这么开放吗妈
Shure: So open-minded, mom.
Shure: 都允许找小的了
Shure: Allowing to find someone younger.
其他人：你的昵称叫什么我忘记给你备注了
Others: What's your nickname? I forgot to save it.
Lucia: 我是那个朱立文建材
Lucia: I'm that Julia Construction Materials.
Shure: 对4个人都好这样是吧
Shure: Right, all four of us are good with this, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
其他人：突然有点不好搜
Others: Suddenly it's a bit hard to search.
Shure: 还是不止4个妈妈
Shure: It's not just four moms.
Lucia: 就是这个名字
Lucia: It's this name.
Lucia: 他比较长就哈哈
Lucia: It's a bit long, so, haha.
Alice: 刘婷你愿意出多少钱买我的狗
Alice: Liu Ting, how much would you pay for my dog?
其他人：什么你让我花钱
Others: What, you want me to pay?
Alice: 哈哈哈我的狗不值钱吗
Alice: Hahaha, is my dog not worth anything?
Alice: 在外边呢
Alice: It's outside.
Alice: 你能把它迎接回来吗
Alice: Can you go get it?
Alice: 待会再迎接吧
Alice: Maybe later.
Alice: 你愿意出多少买它
Alice: How much would you pay for it?
其他人：不要我的命哈哈哈
Other: Don't take my life, hahaha.
Shure: 你在干嘛
Shure: What are you doing?
其他人：你的心理价位是多少
Other: What's your price range?
Shure: 你在用网易
Shure: Are you using NetEase?
Alice:200
Alice: 200.
Shure: 网易云社交软件是吗
Shure: NetEase Cloud social app, right?
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 上个座要么躺着
Shure: Either sit down or lie down.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 没有口袋的衣服真是太讨厌了
Lucia: Clothes without pockets are so annoying.
Alice:你那你那房间装饰好了吗
Alice: Have you decorated your room yet?
Lucia: 好了
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 就就就这样吧
Lucia: It's done, I guess.
Lucia: 管他呢反正是好了就
Lucia: Whatever, it's done anyway.
Lucia: 呵呵
Lucia: Hehe.
Alice: 你见过我的完整版吗
Alice: Have you seen my complete version?
Lucia: 我可以看一下吗
Lucia: Can I take a look?
Alice: 啊你可以
Alice: Sure, you can.
Lucia: 啊，谢谢
Lucia: 我那个在大家去看之前
Lucia: Before everyone else sees it.
Lucia: 我还再去粘一下
Lucia: I'll stick it again.
Lucia: 因为美纹纸特别容易掉
Lucia: Because the masking tape falls off easily.
其他人：你的不也掉了吗
Other: Didn't yours fall off too?
Alice: 我掉了还没粘上呢
Alice: Mine fell off and I haven't stuck it back yet.
Lucia: 哦没事哈哈
Lucia: Oh, it's fine, haha.
Alice: 好的我去
Alice: Alright, I'll go.
Lucia: 好的那你去修整一下
Lucia: Okay, you go fix it.
Alice: 我去补救一下
Alice: I'll go fix it.
Lucia: 我跟你一起去修整一下
Lucia: I'll go with you to fix it.
Alice: 没关系
Alice: It's okay.
Shure: 有威士忌有朗姆有Tequila
Shure: There's whiskey, rum, and tequila.
Lucia: 哇你的房间好香呀哎
Lucia: Wow, your room smells so nice.
Lucia: 可欣还没有过来
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 那我应该这样有威士忌
Shure: So I should have whiskey...
Lucia: what's wrong sorry
Lucia: What's wrong? Sorry.
Shure: 龙蛇胆狼
Shure: Dragon snake gall wolf.
Alice: 这是巧克力豆
Alice: These are chocolate beans.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:比我命还硬
Alice: Harder than my life.
Lucia: 哎呀我决定过会再再冲他
Lucia: Oh, I decided to charge at it again later.
Lucia: 太头大了
Lucia: The head is too big.
Alice: 哦 有一点碎的下面有
Alice: Oh, it's a bit broken at the bottom.
Alice: 刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
刘婷: 干啥
Alice: 你吃巧克力吗
Alice: Do you eat chocolate?
Alice: 给
Alice: Here.
其他人：哦我前两天我把他那个日期设置
Others: Oh, I set the date the other day.
其他人：设置好了
Others: Got it set.
Alice: 好吃吗
Alice: Is it tasty?
Alice: 好吃这个都给你吃
Alice: If you like it, you can have it all.
Alice: 这个反正用不上
Alice: We won't use it anyway.
Alice:给吧
Alice: Here you go.
Shure: 小时候那个打出来的都带
Shure: Back in the day, they all had this.
Alice: 公主请吃
Alice: Princess, please have some.
Shure: 那个
Shure: That thing...
其他人：五十几张
Others: Fifty-some sheets.
Shure: 我们
Shure: We...
Alice: 拿湿了没事
Alice: It's okay if it gets wet.
其他人：因为我带了一盒新的嘛
Others: Because I brought a new box.
Alice: 用不完用完了真疼啊
Alice: If we can't finish it, it really hurts.
Lucia: 这网怎么这么差
Lucia: Why is the internet so bad?
其他人：然后那个啊好像拍到了22
Others: And then, it seems like it recorded up to 22.
Tasha: 然后这个就可以拿上去了
Tasha: Then this can be taken up.
Tasha: 但是也可以最后在拿就是一起拿
Tasha: But we can also take it all at once later.
Tasha: 蛋塔还没烤还要半个小时就全部做完了
Tasha: The egg tarts are still baking, it’ll be another half hour until everything's done.
Tasha: 这个冰一下的话会变硬
Tasha: If we freeze this, it will get hard.
Tasha: 趁热吃
Tasha: Eat it while it's hot.
Tasha: 不拉丝了
Tasha: It won't stretch anymore.
Tasha: 然后提拉米苏拿出来
Tasha: Then take out the tiramisu.
Alice: 嗯咋了
Alice: Hmm, what's up?
其他人：你有一根头发
Others: You have a hair.
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Oh my god.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice: 我们的抹茶粉
Alice: Our matcha powder.
Tasha: 衣服拿一下吧
Tasha: Can you grab the clothes?
Alice:抹茶粉去哪里了
Alice: Where did the matcha powder go?
Jake: 就这么搞是吧
Jake: Just do it like this, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice:恩
Alice: Mhmm.
Tasha: 这能都洗一下吗
Tasha: Can we wash all of this?
Alice: 不要偷吃刘婷
Alice: Don't sneak a bite, Liu Ting.
Alice: 我指名点姓的提醒你
Alice: I'm specifically reminding you.
其他人：只能点名
Others: You can only mention names.
其他人：污蔑我哈
Others: Slandering me, huh?
Alice: 不会吧
Alice: No way.
Alice: 你不会偷吃吧
Alice: You wouldn't sneak food, right?
其他人：你是不是被鬼上身了
Others: Are you possessed by a ghost?
Alice: 不是本人
Alice: It's not me.
Alice: 刚刚好像有什么东西上我身了
Alice: It felt like something just possessed me.
Alice: 哈哈哈退退
Alice: Hahaha, go away, go away.
Alice: 退退退
Alice: Go away, go away, go away.
Tasha: 开一下开啊
Tasha: Open it, open it.
其他人：帮我撕一下行吗
Others: Can you tear this for me?
Lucia: 嗯那个
Lucia: Um, that...
Alice:我来开吧
Alice: Let me open it.
Lucia: 呃要几张
Lucia: Uh, how many sheets?
Lucia: 两张一张
Lucia: Two sheets or one?
其他人：一张吧
Others: Just one.
Shure: 谁知道了
Shure: Who knows?
Alice: 小心要往死里烫
Alice: Be careful, it'll burn you badly.
Tasha: 没事没事别动
Tasha: It's okay, it's okay, don't move.
Shure: 拍哪个小哥哥忘关了啊
Shure: Which guy forgot to turn it off?
Shure: 人类拍照是这样拍的
Shure: This is how humans take photos.
Tasha: 好了吗筛子要用
Tasha: Is it ready? We need the sieve.
Alice: 你跟我在一块那么久
Alice: You've been with me for so long.
Alice: 你你不找我
Alice: You don't look for me.
Alice: 手机壳啥样
Alice: What does your phone case look like?
Alice:你刚刚那个声音是从哪传出来的
Alice: Where did that sound come from earlier?
其他人：这是我的吧哦我的
Others: This is mine, oh, it's mine.
Alice:你有
Alice: You have it.
其他人：这看起来好吃啊
Others: This looks delicious.
Tasha: 嗯湿的不行
Tasha: Yeah, it's too wet.
Alice:爱情好像流沙
Alice: Love is like quicksand.
Lucia: 哈喽啊
Lucia: Hello there.
其他人：开工了
Others: Let's get to work.
Lucia: 呃对他们在做蛋糕
Lucia: Uh, yeah, they're making a cake.
Lucia: 但是我有个小伙伴马上要到附近了
Lucia: But a friend of mine is about to arrive nearby.
Lucia: 所以我对所以我稍等一会
Lucia: So I'll wait for a bit.
Lucia: 然后去接一下他
Lucia: And then go pick him up.
Lucia: 然后再看我们接下来做什么
Lucia: And then see what we do next.
Lucia: 就先在这
Lucia: Just stay here for now.
Lucia: 等一会吧
Lucia: Wait a moment.
Lucia: 怎么感觉这纸好像可以用的呀
Lucia: Why does it feel like this paper can be used?
Lucia: 外面好晒呦
Lucia: It's so sunny outside.
Lucia: 又在抽烟
Lucia: Smoking again.
其他人：笑了这个
Others: This is funny.
其他人：之前
Others: Before...
其他人：开车学姐不小心给我扣分了
Others: While driving, the senior accidentally got me a penalty.
其他人：然后给我买了烟哈哈哈
Others: Then she bought me cigarettes, haha.
Lucia: 想抽还找借口嘿
Lucia: Just looking for an excuse to smoke, huh?
其他人：尝一尝没抽过
Others: Just wanted to try, never smoked before.
Lucia: 你不是说等到哪个月来着
Lucia: Didn't you say you'd wait until some month?
Lucia: 你上次说你就不抽了吗
Lucia: Didn't you say you wouldn't smoke anymore last time?
Lucia: 我记得
Lucia: I remember.
Lucia: 是不有啊哈哈
Lucia: Isn't that right, haha.
其他人：就是没有
Others: No, it's not.
Lucia: 很快就会来的放心吧
Lucia: It'll come soon, don't worry.
Lucia: 放心吧
Lucia: Don't worry.
Lucia: 啊这几个串就串在中间
Lucia: Ah, these few skewers just go in the middle.
Lucia: 其实中间看看咋整
Lucia: Actually, let's see how to arrange the middle part.
Lucia: 1234个吧
Lucia: Maybe four of them?
Lucia: 你现在是想去哪个学校
Lucia: Which school do you want to go to now?
其他人：我想随便去一个地方读博士
Others: I want to go anywhere to get a PhD.
Lucia: 啊直博
Lucia: Oh, straight PhD.
Lucia: 那你就得得去美国吧
Lucia: Then you should go to the US.
Lucia: 别的
Lucia: Otherwise...
其他人：去不了美国
Others: Can't go to the US.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 那但是嗯
Lucia: But, um...
Lucia: 因为我记得反正
Lucia: Because I remember anyway...
Lucia: 反正英国好像是要有硕士才能读博
Lucia: Anyway, I think you need a master's to do a PhD in the UK.
其他人：但是英国读CSG钱太少了还得自己贴钱读
Others: But studying CSG in the UK has too little funding, you have to pay out of pocket.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 不在伦敦的话我觉得反正还还行
Lucia: If it's not in London, I think it's manageable.
其他人：确实
Others: True.
Lucia: 但是在伦敦确实不太够
Lucia: But in London, it's really not enough.
Lucia: 伦敦房租太高
Lucia: Rent in London is too high.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Sigh.
Lucia: 香港那你可以去港大
Lucia: For Hong Kong, you could go to HKU.
Lucia: 你们大概是几月份
Lucia: When will you probably...
Lucia: 就是能拿到比较确定的结果
Lucia: ...get more definite results?
其他人：嗯我现在属于一个
Other: Hmm, right now I belong to a...
其他人：肯定要概括的讲我不知道
Other: I definitely need to summarize, but I don't know.
Lucia: 你之前联系导师套词了吗
Lucia: Did you contact your advisor to get some tips before?
Lucia: 我觉得只要套过
Lucia: I think as long as you did that...
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 那你要不然就等一个学期
Lucia: Then maybe you should wait for a semester.
Lucia: 如果说实在觉得那个啥的话没事
Lucia: If you really feel that way, it's okay.
Lucia: 没事的你看我是去年年底回来
Lucia: It's fine, look, I came back at the end of last year.
Lucia: 我也在盖铺
Lucia: I'm also waiting.
Lucia: 然我现在期待的是等那个啥
Lucia: Now I'm just waiting for that thing.
Lucia: 我也在等最后的结果
Lucia: I'm also waiting for the final result.
Lucia: 所以嗯
Lucia: So, hmm.
Lucia: 我懂确实很头大
Lucia: I understand, it's really stressful.
Lucia: 我我其实
Lucia: I, I actually...
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 然后因为我理论上说今年今年下半年
Lucia: And theoretically, this year, this second half of the year...
其他人：89月份开始套
Other: Start getting tips in August or September.
Lucia: 对然后我去年升的是那个二硕
Lucia: Yeah, and last year I applied for the second master's.
Lucia: 我已经升了
Lucia: 然后现在在等奖学金
Lucia: Now I'm waiting for the scholarship.
Lucia: 就是等奖学金结果
Lucia: Just waiting for the scholarship result.
Lucia: 如果有比较好的结果我就会去
Lucia: If the result is good, I'll go.
其他人：硕士也有CSC
Other: There are CSC scholarships for master's too?
Lucia: 呃硕士一个是有CSC
Lucia: Uh, yeah, there's CSC for master's.
Lucia: 一个你可以申校学校的奖学金嘛
Lucia: And you can apply for the school's scholarship too.
Lucia: 但是反正就是都很慢
Lucia: But anyway, it's all very slow.
Lucia: 就是学校那边会快一点
Lucia: The school's side is a bit faster.
Lucia: 如果你要干argue就慢sic
Lucia: If you want to argue, it's slow.
Lucia: 的话就就就很慢
Lucia: Then it's just, just, just very slow.
Lucia: that's it
Lucia: That's it.
Lucia: 就是挺麻烦的
Lucia: It's quite troublesome.
Lucia: 唉
Lucia: Sigh.
Lucia: 干
Lucia: Ugh.
Lucia: 嗯可能这两年就业形势不好吧
Lucia: Hmm, maybe the job market is bad these two years.
Lucia: 没有没有没有没有没有没有
Lucia: No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Lucia: 我要求不高
Lucia: My expectations aren't high.
其他人：我现在要求也不高
Other: My expectations aren't high now either.
其他人：我现在他妈搞5个
Other: I'm trying to get five jobs now.
其他人：哪个要我都行
Other: I'll take any one that wants me.
Lucia: 我主要我主要是比较比较懒
Lucia: Mainly, I'm just kinda lazy.
其他人：过段时间试一下港舞
Lucia: 我觉得你们走港舞应该很容易吧
Lucia: I think it should be pretty easy for you guys to do the Hong Kong dance, right?
Lucia: 像你们因为你们是理工科的强校
Lucia: Since you guys are from a strong science and engineering school.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 觉想去还是很容易的
Lucia: I think it would be quite easy for you to get it.
Lucia: 唉
Lucia: 而且我关键是
Lucia: And the main thing is,
Lucia: 我手边还有一些别的
Lucia: I have some other
Lucia: 乱七八糟的事情
Lucia: random stuff to handle.
Lucia: 要弄
Lucia: It's a bit of a headache.
Lucia: 所以就有点头疼
Lucia: So it's kinda giving me a headache.
Lucia: 看看我小伙伴到了没有
Lucia: Let me see if my friend has arrived.
Lucia: 到了他应该会给我发消息的
Lucia: He should text me if he's here.
Lucia: 不着急慢慢来
Lucia: No rush, take it easy.
Jake: 你干嘛呢
Jake: What are you doing?
其他人：跟他聊天
Others: Just chatting with him.
Jake: 呵呵呵呆
Jake: Haha, silly.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我在我在等我的小伙伴来
Lucia: Hahaha, I'm waiting for my friend to come.
Jake: 没有这么火
Jake: It's not that popular.
Lucia: 他应该一会就到了
Lucia: He should be here soon.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 电足是吗
Jake: Is the power enough?
其他人：这你打火机
Others: Here’s your lighter.
Jake: 电是开着的
Jake: The power is on.
Lucia: 电很难说它足不足
Lucia: It's hard to say if the power is enough.
Lucia: 因为我衣服上没口袋
Lucia: Because my clothes don't have pockets.
Lucia: 所以我刚站着的时候就把它取下来了
Lucia: So I took it off when I was standing.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 有必要一会再连一下
Lucia: We might need to connect it again later.
Jake: 这个充电宝是你的吗这是谁的
Jake: Is this power bank yours? Whose is this?
Jake: OK行
Jake: OK, got it.
Lucia: heart to say足不足
Lucia: Hard to say if it's enough.
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good.
Lucia: 谢谢理论上他应该比这大一点
Lucia: Thanks, theoretically it should be a bit bigger.
Lucia: 这太小我觉得我手都塞不进去
Lucia: This is too small, I don't think my hand can fit in.
Lucia: 而且也没有那个啥
Lucia: And it doesn't have that...
Lucia: 而且就这个这个这个这个这个脚
Lucia: Also, this, this, this, this leg...
Lucia: 他应该烫的更那个啥一点
Lucia: It should be ironed more precisely.
Lucia: 烫的更仔细一点
Lucia: Ironed more carefully.
Jake:没有买一点你再买一点
Jake: If you don't have enough, buy some more.
Lucia: 现在就哎
Lucia: Right now? Ugh.
Lucia: 而且不好固定
Lucia: And it's hard to secure.
Lucia: 缺乏很多材料
Lucia: We're missing a lot of materials.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Ugh.
Lucia: 好难固定啊靠
Lucia: It's so hard to fix, damn it.
其他人：不对劲了
Others: Something's wrong.
其他人：他妈的我被骗了
Others: Damn, I've been tricked.
其他人：搞什么鬼
Others: What the hell is going on?
Lucia: 农夫山泉为什么这么贵啊
Lucia: Why is Nongfu Spring so expensive?
Jake: 谢斌竹你来执行任务吧
Jake: Xie Binzhu, you take on the task.
其他人：你说
Others: You say it.
Jake: 一些采购任务
Jake: Some procurement tasks.
其他人：采购任务现在就买
Others: Procurement tasks, buy it now.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 买来水然后一个大披萨
Jake: Buy water and a large pizza.
其他人：买一个水
Others: Buy one water.
Jake: 我要大披萨
Jake: I want a large pizza.
Jake: 来把修硕给弄上了
Jake: Come on, bring Shure in.
Jake: 修硕
Jake: Shure.
Jake: 你好
Jake: Hello.
Jake: 你来指导一下
Jake: You guide us a bit.
Jake: 买点啥今天我们吃的那个东西
Jake: Buy something, the stuff we ate today.
Shure: 谢老板
Shure: Thank you, boss.
其他人：现在就买啊
Others: Buy it now?
Jake: 没有没有就准备好就行 下个单
Jake: No, no, just get ready and place the order.
Shure: 我们要买什么呢
Shure: What should we buy?
Jake: 下个单到时候一见
Jake: Place the order when you see it.
Shure: 你搜搜有没有战点披萨
Shure: Search for a battle pizza.
其他人：有没有那种外
Others: Is there one outside?
其他人：有没有那种平时买的
Others: Is there the kind we usually buy?
其他人：就是什么超市里买的
Others: Like the ones from the supermarket?
Shure: 超市要买的
Shure: From the supermarket.
Shure: 咱没什么要买的
Shure: We don't have much to buy.
其他人：那我就先买个水嗯
Others: Then I'll just buy some water first.
Shure: 找一个阳光最足的地方是吗
Shure: Find a place with the most sunlight?
Shure: 进行一些光合作用
Shure: To do some photosynthesis?
Shure: 哎呦呦
Shure: Oops.
Shure: 慢点您
Shure: Slow down.
其他人：站点
Others: A station.
Shure: 站点搜索
Shure: Search for a station.
Shure: 卧槽还真有
Shure: Whoa, there really is one.
其他人：到店
Others: To the store.
Shure: 但是到店不行
Shure: But going to the store won't work.
Shure: 那什么还是跑腿
Shure: So, we should still use a delivery service.
Shure: 不是主要只有站点有那个
Shure: The main thing is that only the station has that.
Shure: 就是32寸那种披萨你知道吧
Shure: It's the 32-inch kind of pizza, you know?
Shure: 然后点好那个站点对
Shure: And then place the order at the station, right.
Shure: 要先点好
Shure: You have to order first.
Shure: 好问题
Shure: Good question.
Shure: 搜小程序呢
Shure: Searching for the mini-program.
Lucia: 夏紫檀我同学说是这个院子吗
Lucia: Xia Zitan, my classmate said it's this yard, right?
Lucia: 啊他应该到了吧
Lucia: Oh, he should be here by now.
其他人：啊我陪你去接吧
Others: Oh, I'll go pick him up.
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Okay, sure.
Lucia: 我是不是应该换个鞋
Lucia: Should I change my shoes?
Lucia: 算了先不换了
Lucia: Never mind, I'll just go like this.
Jake: Lucia是去接了吗
Jake: Did Lucia go to pick him up?
其他人：在那个时光旅人5号院那边
Others: Over at Time Traveler Courtyard No. 5.
Jake: 是的哦那很好啊
Jake: Yeah, that's great.
Lucia: 对在哪来着你你在
Lucia: Right, where was it again? You're at...
Jake:那我去
Jake: Then I'll go.
Jake: 对就接55
Jake: Right, just pick him up.
Jake: 就接一下就到就好了
Jake: Just pick him up and he'll be here.
Jake: 让他们坐好吧要不
Jake: Let them have a seat, okay?
Jake:好不对
Jake: Wait, no.
Jake: 对 坐到二楼坐好
Jake: Yeah, have them sit on the second floor.
Lucia: 是长这样吗
Lucia: Does it look like this?
Lucia: 他虽然还在转
Lucia: He's still circling around.
Jake:恩  这儿了这儿了
Jake: Uh-huh, this is it, this is it.
其他人：就是下车的地方确实是有一个
Others: The place where he gets off is indeed there.
其他人：那个院啊
Others: That yard.
Lucia: OK OK好的
Lucia: OK, OK, got it.
其他人：让他直接在下车的地方等就行
Others: Just have him wait right where he gets off.
其他人：好那我就不去了
Others: Okay, then I won't go.
Lucia: 嗯好的好的
Lucia: Yeah, okay, okay.
Jake: 那紫藤让他们到二楼坐好吧
Jake: Violet, have them sit on the second floor.
Jake: 然后一楼
Jake: And then clear the first floor.
其他人：清场
Others: Clear the area.
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 好我今天也穿拖鞋出来了
Lucia: Okay, I came out in slippers today too.
Lucia: 非常的这个
Lucia: Very this...
Lucia: 这个有别样的体验
Lucia: This has a different kind of experience.
Lucia: 总觉得鞋马上就要从脚上甩出去了
Lucia: Always feels like the shoes are about to fly off my feet.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Really?
Lucia: 是啊你穿
Lucia: Yeah, you wear them.
Jake: 鞋挺大
Jake: The shoes are quite big.
Lucia: 你穿拖鞋出来时
Lucia: When you wear slippers out...
Lucia: 不会有一种他要掉的感觉吗
Lucia: Don't you feel like they're about to fall off?
Jake: 没有我因为穿了好多年了 对
Jake: No, because I've worn them for many years. Yeah.
Jake: 又特别熟练
Jake: And I'm particularly skilled at it.
Lucia: 经验丰富
Lucia: Experienced.
Jake: 特别懂衣服
Jake: Especially knowledgeable about clothes.
Jake: 穿拖鞋打篮球
Jake: Playing basketball in slippers.
Jake: 踢足球
Jake: Playing soccer.
Lucia: 啊啊
Lucia: Ah, ah.
Lucia: 你再说一遍哈哈
Lucia: Say that again, haha.
Jake: 真的真的
Jake: Really, really.
Lucia: 拖鞋的100万种打开方式是吗
Lucia: A million ways to wear slippers, right?
Jake:用拖鞋打篮球命中率会高一些
Jake: Using slippers to play basketball might increase your shooting accuracy.
Lucia: 真的假的哦
Lucia: Really, oh.
Lucia: 不是你看我马上就把鞋甩掉了
Lucia: No, look, I'm about to fling my shoes off.
Jake: 这个拖鞋可能还是不太合脚
Jake: These slippers might not fit well.
Jake: 定制一个拖鞋
Jake: Get a custom pair of slippers.
Lucia: 好吧
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 所以您拖鞋是定制的吗
Lucia: So are your slippers custom-made?
Jake: 不是就是众多
Jake: No, just among many.
Jake: 哈喽哈喽哈喽哈喽哈喽
Jake: Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Lucia: 好久不见
Lucia: Long time no see.
Lucia: 我们往那边走
Lucia: Let's walk over there.
Jake:好好对
Jake: Okay, okay, right.
Lucia: 现在就过去是吧OK
Lucia: Heading over now, right? Okay.
Lucia: 对就是这个是
Lucia: Yes, this is...
Lucia: 请靠你来解释一下
Lucia: Please, you explain it.
Jake: 这个是什么中国
Jake: What is this, China...
Jake: 呃叫什么
Jake: Uh, what's it called...
Jake: 村改别墅的发源地
Jake: The birthplace of village-to-villa transformation.
Jake: 哎对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake: 然后这里面都
Jake: And here, it's all...
Jake: 大概是自建的别墅
Jake: Mostly self-built villas.
Jake: 这一片 太大了
Jake: This area is huge.
Jake: 虽然很村
Jake: Although it's very rural.
Jake: 但是外卖都能点了 就能活了
Jake: But as long as we can order takeout, we can survive.
Jake: 自己会做很多东西
Jake: I can make many things myself.
Jake: 对我们整个
Jake: For the whole of us.
Jake: 在这儿整 七天
Jake: We're here for seven days.
Jake: 就为了迎接你们哈哈哈
Jake: Just to welcome you guys, haha.
其他人：你有水吗
Others: Do you have water?
Lucia: 有呃我们其实准备了水
Lucia: Yes, we actually prepared some water.
Lucia: 谢谢你啊
Lucia: Thank you.
Lucia: 你还自己买了水
Lucia: You even bought water yourself.
Lucia: 就是会有饮料和甜点
Lucia: There will be drinks and desserts.
Lucia: 甜点正在做
Lucia: The desserts are being made.
Jake: 你打车来的是
Jake: Did you come by taxi?
Lucia: 哎所以你
Lucia: Oh, so you...
Jake: 你打多久的车过来的
Jake: How long did it take by taxi?
其他人：没有啊地铁啊
Others: No, we took the subway.
Jake: 地铁啊OK
Jake: Subway? OK.
Lucia: 我对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 我跟福清说的是在化妆站附近
Lucia: I told Fuqing it was near the makeup station.
Lucia: 所以就对
Lucia: So, yeah.
Lucia: 所以远吗
Lucia: So, is it far?
Lucia: 其实好像
Lucia: Actually, it seems like...
Lucia: 反正我听同学说好像不太远的样子
Lucia: Anyway, my classmates said it doesn't seem too far.
其他人：1号线还行啊
Others: Line 1 is alright.
Lucia: 那行
Lucia: That's good.
Jake: 今天一号线人多吗
Jake: Was Line 1 crowded today?
其他人： 嗯主要是中间第一趟车不到这边
Others: Hmm, mainly the first train didn't come this way.
其他人：一趟车只到中间那个哦
Others: One train only goes halfway.
Jake:哦OK
Jake: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 如果你想此时可以跟我们一块做甜点
Lucia: If you want, you can join us in making desserts.
Lucia: 因为种种原因
Lucia: Because for various reasons.
Lucia: 本来计划在
Lucia: The original plan was.
Lucia: 就是大家的小伙伴到之前就做好
Lucia: To have them ready before everyone arrived.
Lucia: 但实际上现在正在做哈哈
Lucia: But in reality, we're making them now, haha.
Jake: 我们上二楼然后就开始吧
Jake: Let's go to the second floor and start.
Lucia: 对啊直接上二楼嘛
Lucia: Yeah, let's just go to the second floor.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 或者你可以带着这个上二楼做
Jake: Or you can take this to the second floor and make it there.
Lucia: 请进
Lucia: Please come in.
Lucia: 请进请进
Lucia: Come in, come in.
Katrina: 哈喽哈喽
Katrina: Hello, hello.
Jake: 哈喽哈喽
Jake: Hello, hello.
Jake: 那就齐了
Jake: Alright, everyone's here.
Katrina: 上楼吧速速开始
Katrina: Let's go upstairs and start quickly.
Jake: 上楼吧
Jake: Let's go upstairs.
Katrina: 迟到43分钟哈哈哈
Katrina: Late by 43 minutes, haha.
Lucia: 我们我再找个充电宝把
Lucia: Let me find a power bank.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia: 我的那个啥哎
Lucia: Where's my, uh...
Lucia: 我刚刚那个充电宝的线上哪去了
Lucia: Where did the cable for my power bank go?
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a sec.
Lucia: 这是我的线吗
Lucia: Is this my cable?
Lucia: 哦这是我的线
Lucia: Oh, this is my cable.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 这个吧OK
Lucia: This one, okay.
Lucia: 我们可以先上楼坐一会
Lucia: We can go upstairs and sit for a bit.
Lucia: 然后然后我再下来帮他们做那个甜点
Lucia: Then I'll come down and help them with the dessert.
Lucia: 福建你现在是在北京上班吗
Lucia: Fujian, are you working in Beijing now?
Lucia: 哦哦你在北京上
Lucia: Oh, you're working in Beijing.
其他人：对啊
Others: Yeah.
其他人：now let's welcome today
Others: Now let's welcome today...
Lucia: 我以为你在比如说
Lucia: I thought you were, like...
其他人：杨靖康
Others: Yang Jingkang.
其他人：耶
Others: Yay.
Lucia: 他们在干嘛哈
Lucia: What are they doing, haha.
Lucia: 哈在干嘛这是
Lucia: Haha, what are they doing?
其他人：对就UFC那种
Others: Yeah, like UFC.
Jake: 一一击掌是吧
Jake: A high-five, right?
其他人：对击掌
Others: Yeah, a high-five.
Lucia: 你随便坐随便坐
Lucia: Sit anywhere you like.
Jake:耶耶耶
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 你看你想坐哪
Lucia: Choose where you want to sit.
Lucia: 我去换个鞋
Lucia: I'll go change my shoes.
Lucia: 去吧既然大家都到的差不多了
Lucia: Alright, since everyone's almost here.
Jake:可以
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 要不你坐我旁边
Shure: How about you sit next to me?
Shure: 就坐那个
Shure: Like, sit there.
Katrina: 你们嘉宾坐前面吧
Katrina: You guests should sit in the front.
Lucia: 嘿
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia: 好吵啊
Shure: 把MC的位置让回给我
Shure: Give me back the MC spot.
Katrina: 不是哈哈哈
Katrina: No hahaha.
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hey.
Lucia: 哎嗯没事没事嘉宾座
Lucia: Oh, it's okay, it's okay. Guest seat.
Lucia: 哈哈你俩可以坐一块
Lucia: Haha, you two can sit together.
Lucia: 反正我一会应该还要下去弄那个甜点
Lucia: Anyway, I might have to go down later to make that dessert.
其他人：哦，这是嘉宾座
Shure: 给我来个包呗
Shure: Can you get me a bag?
Katrina: 啥呀哦哦哦sorry
Katrina: What? Oh oh oh, sorry.
其他人：充电宝
Others: Power bank.
Shure: 充电宝
Shure: Power bank.
Katrina: 一点默契都没有
Katrina: No coordination at all.
其他人：靖康拿个充电宝上来
Others: Jingkang, bring a power bank up here.
Shure: 那那个那
Shure: That, that...
Shure: 不是那是给
Shure: No, that was for...
Shure: 给那个空间
Shure: for that space.
Shure: 你怎么能直呼老板大名呢
Shure: How can you call the boss by his name?
其他人：靖康有英文名吗没有
Others: Does Jingkang have an English name? No.
Shure: 他叫JK yes
Shure: He's called JK, yes.
Lucia: 好洋气哦
Lucia: So fancy.
Shure: 下下一秒就感觉又
Shure: In the next second, I feel like...
Lucia: 哦你今天还带了相机
Lucia: Oh, you brought a camera today.
Jake: 什么充电宝
Jake: What power bank?
Lucia: 久违的久违的相机哈哈
Lucia: The long-lost camera, haha.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 我以为你是在南京工作
Lucia: I thought you worked in Nanjing.
Lucia: 所以你是在北京工作
Lucia: So you work in Beijing?
Lucia: 你有啊老乡
Lucia: You have, oh, fellow townsman.
Katrina: 我线
Katrina: My line...
Lucia: 你在南京工作的呀
Lucia: You work in Nanjing?
Lucia: 哎我怎
Lucia: Oh, I...
Lucia: 那我可能是某一次刷到你定位在南京
Lucia: Maybe I saw your location in Nanjing once.
Lucia: 还是怎么回事
Lucia: Or something.
Lucia: 嗯OK OK
Lucia: Hmm, OK OK.
其他人：你现在不也是在这块
Lucia: 我现在在
Lucia: I am now in...
Lucia: 我还在我家那
Lucia: I'm still at my place.
Lucia: 边主要我今年下半年可能还在出国去
Lucia: Mainly, I might go abroad in the second half of this year.
Shure: 我们要开始吗
Shure: Should we start?
其他人：you are now let's welcome today's presenter
Others: You are now, let's welcome today's presenter.
Shure: 等等拿完宝的
Shure: Wait, after we get the treasure.
Lucia: presenter是谁啊
Lucia: Who is the presenter?
Lucia: 森达
Lucia: Senda.
其他人：杨靖康
Others: Yang Jingkang.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, OK.
Lucia: 是
Lucia: Yes.
其他人：感觉没开
Others: Feels like it's not on.
Lucia: 你带的那个吗
Lucia: The one you brought?
其他人：啊你带的那没事
Others: Ah, the one you brought, it's fine.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我
Lucia: Hahaha, I...
Lucia: 我要不我下楼给你拿一瓶咱的
Lucia: Should I go downstairs and get you a bottle of ours?
Lucia: 你要喝啥
Lucia: What do you want to drink?
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 你喝吗他可不喝哈哈哈
Lucia: Do you want a drink? He doesn't drink, haha.
Lucia: 没事人家还没打开呢
Lucia: It's fine, it hasn't been opened yet.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 因为我们前几天刚好买的是同款茶
Lucia: Because we just bought the same tea a few days ago.
Lucia: 然后对大家以为还有给你先放到这
Lucia: So everyone thought we had some, so they left it here for you.
其他人：坐在最前面像个傻缺一样
Others: Sitting at the front like a fool.
Shure: 没有不
Shure: No, not at all.
Shure: 一点不像
Shure: Not even a bit.
Lucia: 啥这个上面吗
Lucia: What, on this one?
其他人：egohorse
Others: Egohorse.
Lucia: egohorse
Jake: 那我们可能也不能 不能开始
Jake: Then maybe we can't, we can't start.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 所以我们
Jake: So we...
Katrina: 谁是主持人你
Katrina: Who is the host, you?
Jake: : 三三点五十
Jake: At 3:30.
Jake: 因为下面的甜点还在准备
Jake: Because the desserts downstairs are still being prepared.
Jake: 所以还有点奶油要挤
Jake: So there's still some cream to be piped.
Lucia: 需要我去celebrate一下吗嗯
Lucia: Do you need me to celebrate a bit? Hmm.
Jake: 我们就开始4点吧
Jake: Let's just start at 4 o'clock.
Lucia: to accelerate
Lucia: To accelerate.
Jake: 就这么4点吧
Jake: Let's do 4 o'clock.
Jake: 好 4点开始
Jake: Okay, 4 o'clock start.
Lucia: 有什么可以帮忙的吗
Lucia: Is there anything I can help with?
Alice: 你的朋友到了吗
Alice: Has your friend arrived?
Lucia: 到了到了
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 我之前以为 啊没事齐了吧应该
Lucia: I thought everyone was here already.
Alice: 现在现在人齐了吗
Alice: Is everyone here now?
Lucia: 如果大家还有朋友没到吗
Lucia: Does anyone still have friends who haven't arrived?
Jake:剪刀
Jake: Scissors.
Jake: 可能要帮师傅翻一下
Jake: You might need to help translate for the master.
Lucia: 啊好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Lucia: 我冲一下手翻啊马上
Lucia: Let me wash my hands real quick.
Alice: 小吗这个口
Alice: Is this opening too small?
Alice: 我可以挤平面吗
Alice: Can I squeeze it flat?
Tasha: 挤吧
Tasha: Go ahead and squeeze it.
Tasha: 要不你把蛋糕这个切 一下行吗
Tasha: Or can you cut this cake?
Alice: 切一下切成两半吗
Alice: Should I cut it in half?
Tasha: 有的要切对半
Tasha: Yes, some need to be cut in half.
Alice: 都切两半
Alice: Cut all of them in half?
Tasha: 有一半切对半就行
Tasha: Just some of them need to be cut in half.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice: 找个刀
Alice: Find a knife.
Alice: 刀在这吗
Alice: Is the knife here?
Alice: 我们的案板呢
Alice: Where's our cutting board?
Lucia: 这个吗
Lucia: Is it this one?
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes.
Alice: : 干净的吗
Alice: Is it clean?
Lucia: 啊小心
Lucia: Ah, be careful.
Lucia: 应该或许大概也许是算一下吧
Lucia: Maybe we should just roughly estimate it.
Alice: 涮一下吧
Alice: Rinse it off.
Lucia: 我去把那个啥翻一下啊
Lucia: I'll go flip that thing.
Lucia: 翻好了OK OK
Lucia: Done flipping, okay, okay.
Tasha: 都把这个壳去掉啊
Tasha: Remove all the shells.
Lucia: 烫啊
Lucia: Hot!
Lucia: 抓不住
Lucia: Can't hold it.
Jake: 我怎么叠了一层下去
Jake: Why did I fold it down?
Lucia: 不行我完全抓不住
Lucia: No, I can't hold it at all.
Lucia: 拆半天光拆下来一个
Lucia: Took me forever to peel just one.
Lucia: 这个呢也不好拆算了
Lucia: This one is also hard to peel, forget it.
Jake:欧欧欧
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Alice:嗨 哎哟没事吧
Alice: Hey, are you okay?
Lucia: 这个一会还用吗
Lucia: Do we still need this later?
Lucia: 要不要再洗一下了
Lucia: Should we wash it again?
Alice:我挤吧
Alice: I'll squeeze it.
Tasha: 不用了都
Tasha: No need to.
Jake:好你们挤完就OK
Jake: Okay, once you finish squeezing, it's all good.
Alice:拿上去
Alice: Take it up.
Lucia: 哎呦
Lucia: Oh my!
Jake: 拿到
Jake: Got it.
Jake: 拿到哪去
Jake: Got it, where to?
Lucia: 这个这是这个
Lucia: This one, this one right here.
Lucia: 那个哪个
Lucia: Which one?
Lucia: 上面的那个吗
Lucia: The one on top?
Jake:这个我们是在这儿摆盘是吗
Jake: Are we plating the dish here?
Lucia: 那边没有电子产品吧
Lucia: There are no electronic devices over there, right?
Jake:那边没有
Jake: There are none over there.
Lucia: 好香啊这葡萄啊
Lucia: These grapes smell so good!
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 你们你们要不暖场
Jake: You guys either warm up the scene...
Jake: 要不下来干活
Jake: ...or get down to work.
Jake: 不能坐着知道不
Jake: Don't just sit there, got it?
Jake: 所谓剧组成员
Jake: As the so-called crew members.
Alice: 咋了
Alice: What's up?
Jake: 把这个收拾
Jake: Clean this up.
Lucia: 暖不了一点
Lucia: Can't warm it up at all.
Jake: 收拾收拾把这个收掉
Jake: Clean it up, put this away.
Shure: 怎么了怎么了
Shure: What's going on?
Katrina: 你的眼眸
Katrina: Your eyes...
其他人：嗯这个晚上还要装盘啊
Others: Hmm, we still have to plate the dish tonight?
Jake:现马上就要蒸呗
Jake: We're steaming it right now.
Tasha: 马上就要装盘不
Tasha: Are we plating it right away?
Tasha: 这样就只有这个
Tasha: So it's just this?
Tasha: 小房子不要
Tasha: No need for the small house.
Jake: 刘帅呢
Jake: Where's Choiszt?
Jake: 董叉叉呢
Jake: Where's Jack?
Jake:  干嘛呢
Jake: What are they doing?
其他人：暖场
Others: Warming up the scene.
Jake: 哈哈 他们他们在暖吗
Jake: Haha, are they really warming up?
Jake:呵maybe
Jake: Heh, maybe.
Shure: 我送你两个字沙雕
Shure: I'll give you two words: silly.
Lucia: 应该差不多了
Lucia: It should be about done.
Alice: 不要
Alice: No.
其他人：都不要了
Others: Don't want it anymore.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
其他人：都扔了
Others: Throw it all away.
Alice: 秘诀
Alice: Secret technique
Lucia: 怒偷一本武林秘籍
Lucia: Steal a martial arts manual in anger
Jake: 唉我去放在这边擦干的是不
Jake: Oh, should I put it here to dry?
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful
Lucia: 那个地方刚擦干要不还是换个地方放
Lucia: That spot was just wiped dry, maybe put it somewhere else
Alice: 是不是饮料洒了
Alice: Did a drink spill?
Lucia: 因为这是纸容易受潮
Lucia: Because this is paper, it gets damp easily
Alice: 怎么闻见一股果汁味呢
Alice: Why do I smell juice?
Lucia: 哈哈是刚才有一瓶那个
Lucia: Haha, there was a bottle of that earlier
Lucia: 这个这是谁的
Lucia: Whose is this?
Alice: 你咋不在上面呢
Alice: Why aren't you upstairs?
Alice: 卫生间那儿呢那上面也有卫生间
Alice: How about the bathroom? There's one upstairs too
Lucia: 上面也有
Lucia: There's one upstairs too
其他人：上面也有
Others: There's one upstairs too
Lucia: 上面也有啊没事你都下来了就去吧
Lucia: There's one upstairs too, but since you're down here, just go
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 还有啥这个要洗掉对吧
Jake: What else? This needs to be washed, right?
Jake: 这些都不要
Jake: These are not needed
Jake: 为什么现在有手套了
Jake: Why are there gloves now?
Alice: 因为刚来的
Alice: Because they just arrived
Alice: 这要不补一点
Alice: Should we add a bit more?
Jake: 这个要丢掉是吧
Jake: This needs to be thrown away, right?
Jake: 这个这个肯定是空的
Jake: This one is definitely empty
Jake: 这些该放哪啊
Jake: Where should these go?
Lucia: 我给他放到那边吧
Lucia: I'll put them over there
Tasha: 这八个都放到空上托盘啊都放到那个小架子上
Tasha: These eight should go on the empty tray, or on that small shelf
Alice: 那个架子脏脏的
Alice: That shelf is dirty
Jake: 这这这八个是吧
Jake: These eight, right?
Tasha: 那就放托盘
Tasha: Then put them on the tray
Jake: 架子脏脏的就垫一下吧
Jake: The shelf is dirty, so let's pad it
Alice: 托盘吧
Alice: Use the tray
Jake: 这个这个纸
Jake: This paper
Lucia: 纸在哎我今天上午还看见
Lucia: The paper... I saw it this morning
Alice: 纸在这
Alice: The paper is here
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Katrina: 哇还有麦旋风吗
Katrina: Wow, is there still McFlurry?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Alice: 对你的麦旋风
Alice: Yeah, your McFlurry
Jake: 我买的麦旋风
Jake: I bought the McFlurry
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: Why?
Jake: 垫垫一下吗
Jake: Should we put a cushion or something?
Katrina: 现在要拿上去吗
Katrina: Should we take it up now?
Katrina: 还是等会他们下来去
Katrina: Or wait for them to come down?
Tasha: 剪很窄的就行了
Tasha: Just cut it very narrow, that's fine.
Alice: 等吧
Alice: Let's wait.
Jake: 这个放在这吧
Jake: Let's just put this here.
Tasha: 剪跟它
Tasha: Cut along with it.
Katrina: 还有3分钟
Katrina: Three more minutes.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice: 好  还有三分钟啥
Alice: Okay, what's in three minutes?
Katrina: 4点开始
Katrina: Starting at 4.
Tasha: 刀剪一下
Tasha: Cut the knife.
Jake: 4点开始
Jake: Starting at 4.
Alice: 在那在那
Alice: It's over there.
Jake: 剪一下
Jake: Cut it.
Lucia: 剪刀用这个地方可以直接撕
Lucia: You can tear it directly with this part of the scissors.
Jake: 有点
Jake: A little bit.
Alice: 这个不好使反正
Alice: This doesn't work well anyway.
Alice:无妨
Alice: It's fine.
Lucia: 因为那个剪刀
Lucia: Because those scissors...
Lucia: 刚才好像不是用来剪快递的吗
Lucia: Weren't they used to cut packages just now?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 啊我已经用来剪它了无所谓了
Alice: Ah, I already used them to cut it, doesn't matter.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Lucia: 啊哈也没事
Lucia: Ah, it's okay.
Jake: 没关系没关系没听见没听见
Jake: It's alright, it's alright, didn't hear it, didn't hear it.
Lucia: 嗯确实会歪
Lucia: Hmm, it does tend to tilt.
Lucia: 外面对角先扔掉sorry
Lucia: Throw away the outside diagonal first, sorry.
Lucia: 嗯这里面有一个那个啥的印
Lucia: Hmm, there's a mark inside here.
Lucia: 那也够吧
Lucia: That's enough, right?
Lucia: 那是研制的私缝
Lucia: That's a private seam from the lab.
Jake: 我们这个摆在上面么
Jake: Should we place this on top?
Jake: 海是摆在下面了
Jake: Or place it below?
Lucia: 这条会不会有点窄
Lucia: This strip might be a bit narrow.
Tasha: 这个还没洗呢
Tasha: This one isn't washed yet.
Lucia: 好像还行但会长出来一点点
Lucia: It seems fine but it will stick out a little bit.
Alice: 剪了吧剪了
Alice: Cut it, cut it.
Alice: 你折一下然后我剪
Alice: You fold it, then I'll cut.
Alice: 按照你的痕迹剪
Alice: Cut along your crease.
Lucia: 这样吗他大概长出来这么多
Lucia: Like this? It will stick out about this much.
Jake: 剪一下剪一下
Jake: Cut it, cut it.
Alice: 在底下呢 底下呢
Alice: It's at the bottom, the bottom.
Jake: 那底下呢
Jake: What about the bottom?
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 感觉这样也行
Lucia: I think this works too.
Alice: 你给我捏捏肩膀好吗
Alice: Can you massage my shoulders?
Alice:哎哟上去吧上去吧
Alice: Oh, go up, go up.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Lucia: 现在应该差不多好
Lucia: It should be good now.
Alice:恩
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 啊水来了
Lucia: Ah, the water is here.
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Jake:来水
Jake: Water's here.
Lucia: 疼
Lucia: Ouch.
Jake: 我们上去喷喷水
Jake: Let's go up and spray some water.
Jake: 这个就往上面摆了
Jake: Just put this on top.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 请大家先喝点矿泉水
Lucia: Please have some mineral water first.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Alice: 那个太长了
Alice: That one is too long.
Alice: 就光底下那个底就行了
Alice: Just the bottom part is fine.
Lucia: 好好看啊
Lucia: Looks so nice.
Alice: 无妨
Alice: No problem.
Lucia: 哦底下是不是还需要一条
Lucia: Oh, does the bottom need another one?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Jake: 一会儿 我们端上去吗
Jake: Should we bring it up later?
Alice: 在上面还是在下边
Alice: On top or bottom?
Jake: 端上去吧下面
Jake: Bring it up, the bottom.
其他人：下面还要干嘛
Others: What else needs to be done at the bottom?
Alice: 没没啥了就等着
Alice: Nothing, just wait.
其他人：这已经做好了
Others: It's already done.
其他人：嗯还要烤吗
Others: Hmm, do we still need to bake it?
Katrina: 这两个都是新的吧
Katrina: These two are new, right?
Alice:哪个
Alice: Which one?
Lucia: 好啊已经烤好了
Lucia: Yeah, they're already baked.
Katrina: 麦旋风
Katrina: McFlurry.
Alice: 地 一个是杨老板的
Alice: One of them is Jake's.
Katrina: 两个都是他的吗
Katrina: Are both of them his?
Alice: 有一个是
Alice: One of them is...
Alice: 另外一个不知道
Alice: Another one, I don't know.
Katrina: 他有预定哪一个吗
Katrina: Did he reserve any of them?
Katrina: 应该都是新的吧
Katrina: They should all be new, right?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Alice:因为昨天这是画的
Alice: Because this was painted yesterday.
Katrina: 我拿我朋友吃
Katrina: I'll take it to my friend to eat.
Tasha: 这个怎么没拿上去哦
Tasha: Why didn't you take this up?
Jake: 不是你你自己会
Jake: Weren't you supposed to do it?
Jake: 卧槽
Jake: What the hell.
Tasha: 还有四个呢
Tasha: There are four more.
Alice: 这呢这这这
Alice: Here, here, here.
Jake: 你是客人是吧
Jake: You're a guest, right?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice: 往上摆吧
Alice: Put it up there.
Alice:那上面呢
Alice: What about up there?